I meet I Sega and this is a little
follow-up to the first what is doing
calculus talk which unfortunately had
some technical difficulties so let's
just jump right in I'm going to talk
about the various additions that have
been made to calculus over the past year
some very elementary stuff some more
advanced stuff and then at the end I
will talk about some ongoing work that
were going to sew difference quotient is
a very very simple function it's really
just a small convenience it's the thing
that gives you the f of X plus h minus f
of X over H but you know you can do
second order difference quotients you
can do multivariate difference quotients
if you so desire but you know it's a
night it's a name thing it's a good
thing to have so what can you do with a
difference quotient well of course you
can compute a derivative so i have a
function G here and if I take the
difference quotient I get that
expression and when i simplify when i
take the limit as h goes to 0 I get the
derivative as I just verified they're
one of the cute and somewhat
underappreciated facts is that you don't
need to compute the first derivative in
order to compute the second derivative
if you compute the second different
quotient and take the limit as as H goes
to zero you know assuming it's a nice c
2 blah blah blah function then you end
up with the second derivative of course
you can also take the difference
quotient of the first derivative and
that's the direct definition of the
second derivative and the limit as H
goes to zero of that is the second
derivative another nice application is
differentiating as visualizing the
derivative so i have a function here and
then i've defined the tangent with base
B
distance H of X using difference
quotient and then I can create a nice
manipulate here and I can move my base
base point be around and then as H goes
to zero I end up with a nice tangent
line and of course on the other side H
can be negative and either way we
approach a tangent line measures so in
version 10 we had arc length area of
volume and region measure of which arc
length had a special form for parametric
formulas so I have arc length year of
our cosine of T sine Phi of T as T goes
from 0 to 2 pi and the assumptions are
that Argo is greater than 0 and lo and
behold the arc length of a circle is
indeed 2 PI R and in 10.2 or thereabouts
about a year ago we added parametric
forms for area and volume so here I
integrate tea from 2 0 to 2 pi and are
from 0 to 1 and i end up with pie or
volume i now have three variables for my
for my region and go from there well
with version 11 we added this parametric
form to region measure so or was that 10
point for some time recently we added it
so now in any dimension including higher
than three dimensions you can find the
volume of a parametric a region so one
of the advantages of this parametric
form over the more familiar region form
is that you can use non Cartesian
coordinates so here I have a surface of
revolution which is this nice nut shape
and that's very easily expressed in
cylindrical coordinates so I can ask for
the area as Z goes from 0 to PI and
theta goes from 0 to 2 pi if I integrate
over all three variables i get the
volume of doughnut so those are some
nice oh sorry ND so so the parametric
form will take an arbitrary
dimensionality of the embedding
dimension and assume one parameter that
you're varying in that and the embedding
right so if I if I if I change this
example here to be and if i added a Z
component here sign of Z sine of T then
now I have a little sinusoid going up
and down around the circle and you end
up with an elliptic function apparently
but right and you know I could have done
5d whatever I wanted and there are
examples of that in the documentation
including in a sphere that's not
embedded in in Euclidean space so that
you stereographic projections on an end
sphere okay so those are some nice
relatively calculus one through two or
three ish sorts of examples my urge you
reduce so the vendor talked about you
sort of really briefly hit upon it but
mostly talking about Mellin transform
but we have my Archie reduce which takes
functions and expresses them in terms of
the mire g function my orgy is a
generalization of the hypergeometric
function and Bill's gave a nice
characterization in a paper about
earlier this year actually sort of its
the set of generalized solutions that
whose series solution only requires a
one-step recurrence so this is fairly
abstract stuff but one of a nice
application of that is integration over
2 reals so if we have a product of two
functions we can we might try to
re-express both of them in terms of my
orgy and the reason for that is and that
looks a little small to me should I Inc
oh I know because I crashed my
magnification I didn't restore the
magnification that looks better so
there's a nice theorem which tells us
that the integral of a product of my
orgies over the reals is in fact a third
Meyer G function so if i have this
product of two functions on the uptick k
times a power then i can integrate that
hope i did not actually evaluate the
second rule I get that and I can compare
with integrate which will produce a very
different looking sort of answer but it
is in fact the same answer okay another
nice topic is the green function so
green function computes a response to a
delta forcing function and the utility
is that for four linear equations then
arbitrary forcing functions can be
solved using convolution so a nice basic
example is you have an RL circuit and so
we have here just sort of the right-hand
side of the equation the operator part
and some initial condition and we ask
for I for the current as a function of
time now for some different forcing
functions a sine Omega T then I can just
integrate the product of the greens
function with the forcing function and I
get a solution out and that's sort of it
goes towards some sinusoidal
steady-state state after some initial
not you know motion another example is
an inhomogeneous wave equation so here
I've
the greens function in a sort of
classical notation where I have one set
of a pair of variables supper if
separated from another pair of variables
and this is the solution to a delta
function for the wave equation and if we
plot that as a function of X and T we
get something which looks like that but
I think it's easier to understand if we
plot a function of X as a function of
taught over time so we have have a
little pulse at the you know T equals 0
at the origin and that pole spreads out
uniformly over time and again if I have
some sort of forcing function for
example this forcing function here I
integrate that against my my greens
function right there and it'll think for
a little while and eventually give us an
answer and and so you can see that the
solution is the string that's being
forced is always sinusoidal but the
amplitude increases over time and these
all value would give us the same answer
to this equation and it's clearly not
just convolving with the greens function
since it evaluated so much faster yes
okay d eigen system devendra gave a very
nice talk yesterday so I'm just going to
briefly mention what it is and give one
example it is gives the eigenvalues and
eigenfunctions of linear differential
operators so we have here laplacian on
the interval 0 to 2 pi 0 to PI and with
boundary garishly condition so it's
forced to zero at the end points and the
eigenvalues are 14 9 and 16 because it's
sine of X is zero at both ends yes sine
of X is equal to 0 both end points and
minus its second derivative is you know
back to sign and so
on so a fancier example is the isotropic
harmonic oscillator so i have laplacian
in three dimensions plus a constant
times sum of squares in the variables
and i specified garishly boundary
conditions this is really saying that
this is going to 0 at infinity because
when I solve you'll see that I say x y
and z are in full regions of 3 so that
means over all of our solve this over
all of our three and we get so this is a
system which we we asked for the first
eight I ghen values and eigen again
values and eigen functions and this is a
system with some degeneracy so there's a
unique ground state but then there are
three eigen states with the second at
the I second energy level basically one
along each axis and then there are five
at order sorry 55 yeah at the next level
and so on and here's a nice
visualization of the different eigen
functions ok so d solve again the vendor
gave a very nice talked yesterday about
all the enhancements we've made to
dissolve but I thought it would be
useful to sort of go over those here
integral equations partial differential
equations over regions and assumptions
option solutions to serum leah villa pro
problems a green function solver so you
can explicitly request via method option
that i tried to use green function it's
also used to automatically in some cases
and so one one of these nice examples
one of the enhanced pdes we have a
particle in a one dimensional box and so
the general solution is just the sum of
X you know phase phase x sinusoids with
arbitrary coefficients C of K and if we
give one of those eigen states as an
initial condition then we get a state a
stationary state just this pure face x
the one sinusoid and it has unit
integral because it's a properly
normalized state but if we give it a sum
of two eigen states or really any other
function other than one of the
eigenstates now there's going to be sort
of non-trivial dependence in the in the
mixture between the two states and you
can see that the probability density
over time changes as the particle
bounces back and forth between the walls
of the box okay so that is what's in 11
0 you can all do this today and these
are some stuffs and so now I'm going to
need to switch from my normal colonel to
my development colonel because this is
stuff that will be coming in 11 1 so we
can now take we can now take derivatives
of symbolic order so if i ask for the
nth derivative of x it'll tell me that
derivative is 1 if n is 1 but it's 0 if
it's any higher order of derivative and
d is assuming that n is a positive
integer so really it's only 1 or 2 or
higher and you really do get 0 for
example if you do cosine then you get
the n pi over 2 as you cycle between the
four functions and so there if you make
a table of values we see we get the
minus sign the minus cosine and all the
way back to co-sign so a nice example of
this is taking the nth derivative of
sine now i compute the nth term in the
Taylor series so I a replace Tex with X
naught and then multiplied by X mine
six not to the end and divided by n
factorial and if I some the series lo
and behold I come back to sine of X so
it's good entire functions really do
some to their Taylor series another
application are sort of formal
differentiation rules so this is the nth
derivative of a product it's a binomial
times you know some some of binomial
coefficients times the respective
derivatives if I create a table of that
you'll notice it comes back back as an
inactive some because otherwise well it
may or may not try to some things but we
don't really want these to all expand
out if we activate that and then make
the table of the first three values we
get the familiar product role but then
the possibly familiar second order
product role and the rarely written
third order product role there's also a
generalization of the chain rule i
believe this is fadi Bruno's rule party
Bruno's role and it looks very
complicated but if we again make a table
then we have you know easy to understand
formulas the first one is clearly the
normal chain rule second one we get the
product of differentiating F and
therefore we get a second G and it's
squared and or we differentiate the G
prime and so on and so this is something
that will definitely make it into 11 one
other things we're currently working on
our index derivatives and I'll
illustrate what exactly i mean by that
with an example documentation
improvement so i will just sort of very
briefly show you where working on a new
version of the deer f page and if if i
were to open it up you would see well
that's really hard to read that this
magnification but you can see there are
now lots and lots of sections basic uses
symbolic functions different kinds of
functions vector arguments integral
transforms also if we I open up the
application section then lots and lots
of sections and sort of one of the
examples is sort of a friend of an
example we saw earlier so I have here a
derivative a function i compute its
derivative and then I have here I
manipulate where I show f prime of five
and a secant line and then as we bring
the two points closer together we see
how the slope of the secant line
approaches so we we have from various
elementary sorts of functions like that
some very advanced applications some
improvements so we we fixed a bunch of
bugs and added a bunch of suggestions so
these are various mostly number
theoretic things so some subset zeta's
and and so forth so yep improvements to
some and we're currently working on
improvements to integrate there was a
talk this morning about melon transforms
in my orgy we're also making some
improvements to how it applies the
newton label lighten its rule but index
derivatives this is sort of my last
example so we have certain functions
which clearly indicate you're talking
about an index variable so if i have
here an inactive table this is sort of a
position vector with components X of K
where K is some variable now when you
differentiate that with respect to x j
you want you don't want that to be
completely zero because there's no XJ
here except you sort of assume that x j
is could possibly be
one of the k's and so what what we've
done is for these functions like table
and some we now recognize that and an ex
of something maybe an index and handle
that appropriately so if you take the
position vector and you differentiate it
with respect to x j you get a Kronecker
Delta either J and K are the same when
you get one or you get zero and a
similar sort of formula if you take the
norm of that vector so that's the sum of
X K squared and differentiate that with
respect to x j and in order to get a
nice simple answer i say i explicitly
say that J is an integer and K is
between one and n then you get to X sub
J and I will just say that as a geometry
I don't believe in the existence of a
position vector which is why it's in
sarcastic air quotes but you know this
sort of index differentiation is
obviously near and dear to my heart as a
geometers but is useful in very very
many areas so that is that is very
likely to make it into 11-1 as well it's
a little bit further out and the nth
derivative stuff and so that is what I
had to say devendra is there anything
else you think we should mention
yes a lot of these examples in the gnudi
ref page I mean some of them are
obviously original to us but some of
them are you know solutions to actual
problems from Stewart spoke so I don't
know how what's that adapted from yes I
guess Stewart might object if we had
solutions to his problems in our
documentation center but and so but yeah
it's a very nice collection of examples
I so I think you'll be quite pleased and
certainly as we add to functionality to
each one of these basic calculus
functions i mean we're now starting to
work on integrate and hopefully we'll
get to limit in the not-too-distant
future we'll be updating the
documentation for each of them so that
it meets the same standards of all the
newer functions which were written later
and therefore got much fancier
documentation pages so question
[Applause]